salut aujourd'hui je réponds à l'une de
vos demandes qui et comment est-ce qu'on
peut engager la conversation c'est pas
une demande que vous m'avez fait
expressément comme ça vous m'avez
souvent demandé comment engager la
conversation pour draguer comment dans
un contexte professionnel vous pouvez y
est abordée quelqu'un ou comment dans
votre vie sociale
vous pouviez parler aux gens et bien je
répond à ces trois questions en une
seule vidéo allez hop génériques à vous
voulez menthe à l'eau avec un os qui
vous demandaient comment engager la
conversation j'y réponds aujourd'hui en
5 astuces première astuce la plus
évidente mais on va quand même cela
rappelait quand vous devez engager la
conversation avec quelqu'un avec une
seule personne n'y ait pas de préjugés
n'ayez pas de crainte
ayez un sourire intérieur mettez-vous de
bonne humeur vous devez vous préparer
mentalement à ne pas avoir de craintes
allaient aborder la personne est allé
converser avec elle est dans un bon état
d'esprit
donc prenez le temps de seconde de
souffler de vous préparer mentalement et
elle hésite deuxième astuce ne cherchez
pas être pertinents une de vos craintes
vient du fait que vous dites ah là là
est ce que ça va être bien ce que je
vais dire est ce que ça va être
intéressant j'ai un secret on s'en fout
vous allez aborder la personne et ça
c'est le plus important ne cherchez pas
être pertinents soyez à la place
contextuel il ya des travaux cette
formidable chez moi désolé pour le bruit
de fond c'est pas un truc que je
maîtrise et comme vous pouvez le
constater il me reste une heure cinq
pour tout faire pour cette vidéo j'ai
mis un peu de temps l'écrire jeu je
disais donc soyez contextuelle et
trouver un prétexte pour parler à la
personne ça c'est plus intéressant
imaginons vous êtes dans une soirée
c'est un nouveau lieu qui vient d'être
inaugurée vous pouvez aborder la
personne tout simplement en allant la
voir en disant qu'ils donc ils ont
vraiment fait un truc incroyable moi je
m'attendais pas à ça et hop c'est parti
la conversation elle démarre prenez le
contexte est retiré un prétexte pour
allez aborder la personne troisième
astuces j'ai lu un jour dans le livre
best-seller comment se faire des amis de
dale carnegie un tout une phrase une
anecdote qu'elle a raconté elle était
allée dans une soirée et on doit
présenter quelqu'un de très cultivé un
médecin et il lui a parlé toute la
soirée
c'est à dire qu'elle n'avait pas parlé
elle l'a juste écouter mais c'est tout
un gars là rien de plus rien de moins
toute manière apparemment il a abordé
des sujets qu'elle maîtrisait pas du
tout et à la fin de la soirée le docteur
en question et aller voir l'autre qui
avait organisé tout ça pour lui dire à
la une conversation incroyable et quelle
culture et c'était vraiment agréable on
a parlé ensemble toute la soirée c'est
faux c'est lui qui a parlé mais dans son
souvenir
elle avait une conversation passionnante
pourquoi pascal là écoutez donc on peut
en retirer cette troisième astuces
fondamentale une conversation nouvelle
avec quelqu'un est plus intéressante
pour ce quelqu'un si vous mettez en
situation d'écouté plutôt qu'en
situation de parler vous tout le temps
quatrième astuces puisque vous allez
l'écouter parler vous allez pouvoir
faire attention à son type de
conversation est-ce que c'est quelqu'un
qui va être plutôt rieurs est-ce que
c'est quelqu'un de très sérieux qu'elles
mettent à fort la personne utilise pour
s'exprimer est ce que c'est une personne
plutôt qui se plaint de tout vous allez
pouvoir vous rebondir là dessus et dans
la même énergie dans le même type de
discussion dans la même manière
d'aborder les choses
donc vous allez était encore plus
intéressant posez-lui quelques questions
vous pouvez aussi faire des relances
même quand vous ne maîtrisez pas du tout
le sujet grâce à la magie de la
reformulation il ya plein de types de
reformulation possible deux sont très
intéressantes la reformulation miroir si
la personne à qui vous êtes en train de
parler vous dis ouais je perds un match
de tennis là et puis on va j'ai perdu
mes habitudes je perds pas votre
formulation ça peut être à d'accord et
donc tu joue au tennis mais apparemment
tu as plutôt un bon niveau à la base
c'est une reformulation miroir la
reformulation empathique aussi elle
marche très très bien vous allez juste
faire une reformulation mais non pas de
ce qu'elle vient de dire mot pour mot
mais de l'émotion kelly amis imaginons
la personne qui est en train de dire et
là je me suis fait voler mon téléphone
portable
donc ça m'a obligé d'aller chercher des
choses des papiers fins déclaration de
vol à j'imagine que tu devais te sentir
énervé de voir faire tout ça ça devait
être très agaçant c'est une relance de
formulation empathique
mais dis donc on serait pas en train
d'arriver à la 5ème astuces la cinquième
astuces à se découpe en cinq points très
rapide mais gardena en tête c'est très
très important c'est presque plus
important que le reste puisque ce sont
les choses à ne pas faire donc 5e
astuces éviter les pièges classiques
enfin la conversation ne doit pas
devenir un interrogatoire non plus fait
de relance c'est bien poser des
questions c'est bien mais ça doit pas
être question questions questions en
question question tout le temps c'est
très désagréable a vu en deux évitez
toute plainte
vous ne devez pas être plaintif ou
énervés ou même si la personne mais ça
c'est pas le problème
vous restez toujours dans votre esprit
positif souriant et bienveillant quand
vous parlez quand vous parlez de vous
mais ne vous plaignez pas troisièmement
éviter d'interrompre la personne quand
elle parle attendait vraiment que ce
soit votre maman parler des fois on a un
truc vraiment qu'on a envie de dire mais
si vous êtes dans cette démarche de
rencontrer quelqu'un surtout pour la
première fois fait très attention à pas
l'interrompre en 4 ne tombez pas dans le
paternalisme
c'est la personne qui fait oui je
comprends mais moi je pense que tu
devrais faire ça parce que tu sais
comment ça se passe il faut faire ci
comme ça comme ça comme ça sur une
première rencontre
ça peut vite soul et le cinquième point
on évite les dallages ne racontez pas
votre vie n'oubliez pas que c'est vous
qui êtes allez aborder la personne on
vous a rien demandé au départ dont cnh
est allé pas comme ça votre cv votre vie
tout ça c'est assez désagréable aussi
même si la personne sourit en réalité
son discours intérieur peut-être tout
autre il y en a qui piège comme ça qui
font des prises d'otages de conversation
il arrive vers toi il te pose deux
questions trois questions et une fois tu
as répondu ils estiment qu'ils ont le
droit à une demi heure de temps de
parole papale et aux loges j'espère
qu'avec ces cinq points vous allez
pouvoir aborder la conversation dans
tout type de situation que ce soit
pourquoi pas d'un de la séduction du
travail dans des relations sociales
classiques et que ça va vous faciliter
la vie si la vidéo vous a plu vous savez
ce que vous avez à faire
il paraît qu'il faut pas le dire alors
je le dis pas mais vous le fait que si
ça vous a plu évidemment vous pouvez
également vous abonner à la chaîne avant
de partir ça c'est très important si
vous l'avez pas déjà fait et sinon le
mental blog c'est une vidéo par jour
pendant un an donc rendez vous demain à
17h chao à non j'ai dit une bêtise
demain et samedi donc rendez vous demain
à 11 heures et ouais les mecs on se
réveille demain ciao
et